bonsoir Léo bon les années précédentes
ont été marquées par évidemment les
aides pandémiques ce sont les mesures
fiscales pour pallier au coût de la vie
qui ont marqué les derniers mois Québec
qui a été plus généreux qu'ailleurs
d'ailleurs Luc oui mais tout à fait
lorsqu'on regarde faut se rappeler dans
le fond les mesures au Québec il y a eu
trois mesures ponctuelles du
gouvernement du Québec une première qui
est annoncée en décembre 2021 mais qui
était versé au début de l'année 2022 on
rajoute à ça le budget de Mars où il y a
eu le premier 500 dollars pour les gens
de et lorsqu'on voit d'ailleurs c'est
l'importance de ces aides donc on voit
c'est que le Québec et c'est là où les
mesures ont été les plus généreuses
trois fois trois et demi fois plus que
toutes les autres provinces canadiennes
ici on présente quelques provinces que
vous voyez l'Alberta l'Ontario qui eux
ont choisi des réductions de taxes sur
l'essence notamment il y avait le
fédéral qui a aussi de bonifier son
crédit TPS qui est ajouté dans chacune
des provinces on pourrait dire le Québec
a été beaucoup plus généreux parce que
les élections mais c'était aussi les
élections en Ontario donc c'est pas le
seul vecteur de d'explications donc ça
c'est le constat effectivement vous
chapitre de la générosité si vous voulez
pour le soutien face au cours de la vie
mais vous avez analysé évidemment toutes
sortes de choses dans votre bilan qui
porte sur 2021 la première année
complète marquée par la pandémie
qu'est-ce qui se démarque là comme
changement fiscaux
dans la structure d'imposition par
rapport à la période avant la pandémie
ce qu'on s'aperçoit au Québec c'est que
la place de l'impôt des sociétés sur le
profit des sociétés les prend plus de
place dans la structure d'imposition au
Québec puis on a regardé dans le reste
du Canada c'est la même tendance donc
l'impôt des sociétés tendance à prendre
plus de place dans les pays avancés de
l'OCDE c'est la même chose donc à des
des pros différents mais il y a une
tendance parce que 2021 est une bonne
année donc à prendre plus de place dans
l'impôt des sociétés parce qu'on a
souvent dit
avec l'inflation la hausse des taxes à
la consommation ça génère plus de
revenus est-ce que on observe que ça
prend de l'ampleur d'abord toutes les
sources de revenus ont gagné en argent
les collègues plus de recettes mais les
taxes à consommation c'est l'inverse de
l'impôt des sociétés ils prennent moins
de place donc aussi au Québec aussi dans
le principal constat dans le les pays de
l'OCDE c'est ça c'est les ions cru moins
vite depuis 2019 donc qui ont perdu de
l'importance dans le total des recettes
contrairement à l'impôt des sociétés
très intéressant bon évidemment
lorsqu'on parle de bilan de la fiscalité
on pense un pot le fait que le Québec
impose traditionnellement un peu plus
que d'autres juridictions quoi qu'on
offre évidemment plus de services pour
la pression fiscale le qu'est-ce qu'elle
a tendance à s'alourdir avec les années
c'est une idée reçue est-ce que ça se
vérifie dans cette vérifie en 2021 dans
les 20 dernières années c'est cette
année-là que le poids du total des
recettes fiscales prélevées au Québec
par toutes les administrations publiques
en proportion de notre économie et le
plus et depuis 2008 la tendance est
allée à hausse pratiquement année après
année de la tendance est à la hausse et
même on pourrait regarder dans les 10
dernières années donc là on a des
chiffres pour les 10 dernières années
c'est deux points 7 points de
pourcentage du PIB de plus donc on
perçoit aujourd'hui 39.6 % du PIB en
recettes fiscale c'est à deux points 7%
de moins en 10 ans plus tôt une
progression quand même non négligeable
ça c'est la tendance vous le disiez pour
le Québec c'est la même chose pour les
autres provinces on a fait l'exercice la
beauté de la chose c'est vrai dans les
10 provinces ça l'a augmenté le poids de
la fiscalité dans les 10 provinces donc
il y a peut-être une part imputable au
gouvernement fédéral aussi là-dedans par
contre ça a pas augmenté de la même
ampleur mais quand on prend l'ensemble
des autres provinces canadiennes
l'augmentation est plus significative
qu'au Québec donc ça veut dire que
l'écart se résorbe dans les 10 dernières
années le poids de la fiscalité au
Québec et dans les autres provinces
canadiennes notamment avec l'Ontario bon
on a l'habitude évidemment de Paris
justement à l'Ontario de se comparaître
des juridictions qui sont proches de
nous mais là dans votre étude vous avez
comparé la fiscalité québécoise avec
celle de la Suède et de l'Australie
pourquoi et comment on se compare
pourquoi c'est une bonne question dans
le fond on a choisi l'Australie parce
que comme le Québec c'est un pays
anglo-saxon puis c'est une fédération
qu'on a choisi la 7 la suite parce que
comme le Québec on a une tendance à
avoir un poids de la fiscalité plus
élevé que la moyenne des pays avancés de
l'OCDE et donc les trois juridictions
c'est qualifié de petites économies
ouvertes donc ça ça c'est ça qui
justifie notre choix là maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut constater ben
rapidement avec la Suède notre seul à
pointe c'est le poids de la fiscalité
dans l'économie mais notre structure
fiscale ressemble beaucoup plus à
l'Australie puis si on regarde dans ce
replant que l'Australie c'est une
fédération puis qu'on regarde la place
des provinces là-bas ou l'équivalent des
provinces mais il y a beaucoup plus
d'autonomie fiscale dans le Canada qu'en
Australie donc le Québec occupe une plus
grande dans la fiscalité ici que un état
en Australie très intéressant je veux
qu'on termine en parlant de déco
fiscalité Luc parce que c'est pas tout
le monde qui est ouvert ou qui est chaud
à l'idée de l'utiliser davantage on a
souvent aussi l'idée que ça ça pèse
relativement lourd mais quand vous avez
fait une analyse comparative avec les
économies avancées de l'OCDE on se rend
compte que les recettes qui proviennent
et là on voit le tableau du poids des
recettes provenant des taxes liées à
l'environnement c'est pas si lourd que
ça finalement on a le Canada en rouge le
Québec en bleu on voit qu'il y a
plusieurs autres pays du G7 ou c'est pas
mal plus lourd que chez nous pour pas
que le tableau soit trop lourd vous avez
choisi les pays du G7 mais si on avait
pris les pays de l'OCDE mais on serait
septième sur 31 là on est on dirait
qu'on est en milieu depuis le temps mais
quand on rajoute d'autres pays sont
souvent plus élevés que nous par contre
faut aussi voir on est dans un
environnement nord-américain regardez le
Canada les États-Unis c'est moins que
nous donc le Québec se trouve très
faible à travers les pays de l'OCDE mais
à travers les promesses canadiennes
c'est l'endroit le plus figure souvent
parmi l'endroit les plus élevés donc
faut garder ça on est un peu le paradoxe
ou la peinture entre les deux sortes
d'analyse là très bien c'est très
intéressant on va s'arrêter là-dessus et
on aura le grand plaisir de se reparler
à mettre reprise en 2023 merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI